Doctor, es que yo soy un paciente
quirúrgico, pero me están ofreciendo
resolver mi tratamiento solamente con
brackets. No lo hagas. A ver, o por lo
menos no lo hagas con cualquier
ortodoncista. Este tipo de casos son de
alta complejidad. No todos los
ortodoncistas tienen las mismas
habilidades. Hay algunos que se han
especializado en tratar este tipo de
pacientes que no se quieren operar o por
algún motivo no pueden hacerlo. Este
tipo de tratamientos no son estables en
el tiempo y si tratan de acomodar los
dientes sin tener el hueso en las
condiciones correctas, sin ser un
paciente de clase uno esquelética, no
solamente atentará en contra de la
posición de los dientes, sino también en
la salud de la enía, de la articulación
temporomandibular y de muchas otras
partes del sistema que ni siquiera
posiblemente sepas. definitivamente
busca la opción quirúrgica.